fox news alert in a stunning development
bill cosby is a free man
the disgraced entertainer appearing with
his legal team
outside his house just moments ago
mr cosby has always used his celebrity
his name his likeness to uplift women
how could a man who was being watched by
the fbi
every day be raping and drugging women
in the 60s or 70s especially a black man
today just came to mr cosby
mr cosby we knew all along he never
should have been prosecuted for this he
had every right to rely on the
prosecutor's word
and they pulled the rug out from
underneath him because of politics
because of the court of public opinion
and that is not how our system should
operate
the actor once known as america's dad
returning home after being led out of
prison on a technicality
the pennsylvania supreme court
overturning his
2015 sexual assault conviction the court
ruled that a non-prosecution agreement
with a previous prosecutor
should have prevented cosby from being
charged in that case
a jury found cosby guilty of drugging
and raping temple university sports
administrator
andrea constand at his house in 2004.
he was the first person to fall in the
me too movement after dozens of women
claimed
that he drugged them and molested them
but now
the 83 year old is now a free man
so dana we heard from the cosby team out
there in the driveway of pennsylvania
kind of making cosby out to be the
leader of the me too movement if you
take them at their work and they're
almost you i can understand winning a
case you feel very good about it this
was a technicality
technicalities matter in our system so i
mean this
this can happen um i think that for the
women who came forward who testified
it's a sad day for them i think that it
came out of the blue
i wasn't expecting this news and i know
i guess it was working its way through
the system but you don't really
expect a technicality like this to
overturn a jury
trial but that's what's happened and
he is a free man he is home he's he i
think he was in
for two of two years of a 10-year
sentence yeah
two years into a three to ten year
sentence
and 4-3 decision by the pennsylvania
supreme court greg
i i did not expect this either
i did yeah i'm watching this closely i'm
sure you have yeah i feel bad for you
jesse because while he was in prison you
were in a sense america's dad
people have referred to me as that yeah
uh i was hoping you were gonna go to
harold because he knows everything about
this but i'm gonna steal all his talking
points okay
they did cross a line right they did
cross a line and we don't know if they
would have been able to convict him if
they hadn't crossed the line
so he has to go free because they
screwed up
and that's the reason the the question
is how come
we didn't nobody really in the media
knew about this but there was one person
who did
and his name rhymes with geraldo rivera
who claimed that he was the guy that
said
you know the court was tainted by public
opinion and social pressure that
prejudiced the evidence
uh and the and the and allowed for
improper witnesses
and he and i think geraldo's word was
that even though it doesn't matter
whether cause he's a bad guy
uh he was railroaded so i it's kind of
an interesting thing because
uh i i mean i if i get involved in a
crime i'm gonna try to make sure
it's as scandalous as possible cause i
want i want i don't want the court to
function objectively
that way i can always win the appeal but
in terms of public opinion
this is a really good point to be made
especially now that
justice can be overwhelmed by public
opinion which is now
magnified by social media because if you
remember the time that this was going on
there was no way
he could be innocent because all you
heard all the time
because you believe when you see the
stuff on social media you know
he how can he be innocent you know and
then he's got his team working around
the clock uh
he should buy them all drinks but they
shouldn't drink it oh gosh
so as greg mentioned there was a deal by
the
district attorney in pennsylvania herald
and he didn't think he could get a
conviction on a criminal charge
so he said we're not going to prosecute
you criminally we're going to do a civil
case
and so cosby thinks hey i'm clear with
criminal charges i'm going to be deposed
in the civil case
ends up saying yeah i did give girls
quaaludes
and then years later new teams of
prosecutors came in
disregard this agreement and then charge
the heck out of this guy
you think that was prosecutorial i don't
know
overreach well evidently the
pennsylvania supreme court thinks that
there was prosecutorial misconduct
look i don't think bill cosby would say
that he's a saint um
and whether we agree with the outcome of
the trial or not what is clear is the
supreme court says you can't
prosecute a person this way we should
all
be thankful that our system is
predicated and built around protecting
individual rights they're going to be
outcomes that we don't like in legal
cases
in fact the most recent case it got a
lot of attention this police officer
derek shoving in minnesota he got a
trial
and the prosecution had to put on a case
that's how our system works
and if there was prosecutorial
misconduct in this case with bill cosby
a shame on those prosecutors because if
he did the things that they claim that
he did and he gets off on this because
they didn't do their job right anyone
said i'd be upset with them
because they were the ones that didn't
didn't do their job correctly and then
follow the law
and katie a jury still did putting aside
this agreement that was
trashed they still looked at the
evidence and found him guilty
yeah there's that and as you mentioned
the 2005 civil suit where he admitted
and the documents were released that he
did in fact
buy drugs to give to women that he
wanted to have sex with so
that is on the record from bill cosby
unfortunately you know if you really
truly believe in victims rights
and you want justice for victims you
have to believe that the technicalities
matter
you have to get rid of the mob you have
to take out the emotional side of this
because in the end
the people here who are going to suffer
are the victims of something that bill
cosby
admitted to doing and there are cases
like this that play out all of the time
as a result of
emotion getting into the courtroom or
prosecutors not doing their job the
right way
and then the victims who have spent
decades of their life
trying to get what they deserve in terms
of some kind of justice for crimes that
were committed against them
that all goes away in the blink of an
eye like today because
the things weren't done the right way i
believe that
it's a good thing that the the system
has all these protections built in for
the accused and it's up to and it has
the responsibility of the prosecutors uh
and the judges and the jury
to stick to the rules that we have in
the constitution in order to protect
the rights of victims so that they get
the justice that they deserve is cosby
still in the clear do you think dana do
you think people are going to come out
of the woodwork and
i don't know years years years after the
fact maybe file additional charges
just to really i don't know get justice
for any of the women that are still out
there so for the
prosecutor that screwed up and their and
their team
i would imagine that they're going to
feel a desire to try to make it right
yeah
and they just might not be able to do
that i don't think the supreme court
barred it
if you said he can't be prosecuted again
but a civil case in pennsylvania
i mean sure there's got to be other
women out there right there almost could
be dozens of women for
for losing time like if this was an inju
an injustice he should be the one that
is suing for the two years of his lost
life
to your to your point when you get older
that time is
more it's like the percentage of your
life i don't know i can't do the math
you've done it before me before but if
you're in your 80s
and you just spent two over two years in
prison and you were there
wrongly on a technicality it's worth
more if the taxpayers of pennsylvania
have to pay a claim
right bill cosby yeah the other part of
this too is if you look at it from the
perspective of a woman
who maybe hasn't come forward yet or
hasn't gone through the process of
filing
either a civil lawsuit or a criminal
case if you look at
this and the people the prosecutors who
are supposed to be pursuing justice on
your behalf and protecting you
screwed it up this way after you get a
conviction from a jury
why would you put yourself through it in
a lot of instances right they probably
feel pretty
beaten down by what happened today yeah
demoralizing for a lot of people thank
you katie hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else